Now that we've familiarize ourselves with the normal distribution,
let's discuss one of the most common parametric test
that we might use to compare two sets of
data. Such as our samples of left handed and right
handed [INAUDIBLE], that would be the t-test. The t-test
like many statistical tests aims at accepting or rejecting
a null hypothesis. A null hypothesis is generally a
statement that we're trying to disprove by running our test.
For example, that two samples came from the same
population. This might mean that left-handed and right-handed batters show
no real difference in their batting average, or that
a certain sample is drawn from a particular probability distribution.
For example, if we had a sample of 20
heights and weights of Arbitrary baseball players, we might want
to test how likely it is that those 20 people
are drawn from the known MLB player population. A hypothesis
test such as the t-test is usually specified in
terms of a test statistic. The test statistic reduces
your data set to one number that helps to
accept or reject the null hypothesis. When performing a T-test,
we compute a test statistic called T. Depending on
the value of the test statistic T, we can determine
whether or not or null hypothesis is true. In
the case of the one sample T-test, our null hypothesis
would be that the population mean, mu, is equal to our
sample mean, mu not. In the T sample case, which we'll be
more concerned about for the purposes of our example, The null
hypothesis would be about our population means, m0 and m1 are equal.